yo it's brian moses from rose battle and
check out the bootleg rogan
i mean i mean bootleg kev podcast i'm on
there
bootleghead podcast special guest in
here my good friend the very funny why
moses
well special guest is anybody a special
guest on your show
yeah i guess that do i say that for
everybody i don't say i don't say
special guests for everybody but i guess
everyone's special everyone's special in
their own way thank you thank you
bootleg rogan thank you does he say that
no you just got you get that look this
is like you know the bootleg kev show
you this bootleg rogan look you know
what i got going on a little bit yeah
bro bald you know
except for i'm fat
you're a thick player i've been watching
joe rogan and i'm like man this
[ __ ] make me feel like just like
i ain't doing [ __ ] this works out
[ __ ]
eats right
yeah the end yeah you got
he's like energy drinks i think he just
celebrated his like
55th birthday or something
no joe rogan's like 300 he's like he's
as old as his money is on spotify like
he's like 300 million
300 million years old that's a lot uh
yeah yeah well you know me you and you
and i met in austin for the first time
on raya yeah yeah uh i uh went out there
with fred gibbs who you brought on to
the rogan show with you name drop name
drop name drop and um we had an
interesting weekend
we did kev we uh yeah we were i tell
this story about my bad mushroom chip in
texas and you're one of the few people
who are actually there for that yeah you
were angry
i was just freaking the [ __ ] out
and then i gave you mushrooms the next
night and then you ended up i was i
don't know if you got beat up or you
ended up yeah in front of some there was
this really annoying white lady who was
following us around
do you remember that lady yeah it was a
friend trying to be friends with me and
i just kept looking at her like i'm
[ __ ] up leave me alone yeah weird-ass
white woman yeah you don't like her i
did i was not a fan yeah you weren't a
fan of that white woman that weekend
that was it was a weekend that was your
black lives matter protest
and shout out to all the homeless people
that were there too when we were on
because we were really just hanging out
on in on six for the most part yeah and
i was like this is just la but smaller
and like barbecue yeah and hotter and
then uglier you know what i mean yeah
yeah like la's like cousin like yeah you
could smash probably right right and
then like you don't have to call her
back
that's austin shout out to austin yeah
no we had a good time out there um
how long have you known uh the rogan man
because you've been you've been on the
show multiple times at this point yeah
yeah he came uh to the back to the store
like 2014 2015 i'd say so i probably met
him around then and you had been doing
how long have you been doing your staple
there you've been doing uh i've been on
the road yeah we started we started in
like july 2013. jeff ross got up
involved around december
2013 kind of a thing and then we just
kind of rode that [ __ ] out until we
sold it in 2016.
so when you sold it uh it's obviously
ended up on tv give it give everyone
like a background on well kevin well
yeah yeah for people who don't know
you're obviously a great comedian and
roast battle was kind of like your baby
right so yeah
to this day on tuesdays at the comedy
store she was like my side project then
she became like my main [ __ ] uh yeah so
we still do every tuesday we live
streaming if you're into you know
watching [ __ ] like at home and being
lazy um it's on mint comedy so they
partnered with verizon media so [ __ ]
looks ill you know looks like a netflix
special but we're just in the comedy
store being stupid uh but yeah we
started as like like a you know for a
it's like a comedy fight club kind of a
thing guys who didn't like each other
guys who just wanted to like talk [ __ ]
about each other in front of a room of
their peers that's kind of what it was
because it was an open mic um that was
wrong with my homegirl and then uh she
took off and then we brought it back and
we brought it back it was just like a
lot of that that toxic male energy they
talk about yeah
love that you know what i mean so then
uh it was just being like a skate park
and then uh these two cats were talking
[ __ ] one who worked there and then
another one who was just like kind of
like you know a new guy on the scene and
then kenny lyon josh martin i'll say
your names
but uh yeah we want those cats to slap
box oh yeah but they just installed
cameras at the comedy store so i was
like we can't you know we can't be like
bum fights
crazy so uh we told them to talk some
[ __ ] about each other like a bunch of
people were like y'all you just talk
[ __ ] about each other and little well
yeah you're nate you know like we're
like it's a roman coliseum and that was
it and then every tuesday since [ __ ]
just want to talk [ __ ] to each other in
front of everybody yeah no i i went uh
and checked it out and it was
it was like
zero [ __ ] given [ __ ] talking that's
amazing yeah it's it is the uh it's the
church of free speech as uh if we're
gonna name drop john mayer says it's
like a temple of a free yeah there's so
like every week you have
like there's like judges right yeah so
it's like the judges change from week to
week right so yeah special guest judges
it's cool it's got like that real
speakeasy thing like have you heard
about this thing that's kind of how it
started and then jeff would bring his
famous friends right and then you know
people would get
acquainted with the show and they'd be
like i'm just going to come and people
just like came bro like you had a jim
carrey thing there you had brett radner
who you know directed all the
rush hours yeah that cat you had the
wolf of wall street come through one the
actual one jordan balfour he actually
came yeah i watch his podcast sometimes
yeah he came through
uh one of the andretti kids i mean
chappelle uh a tell i mean the listener
oh yeah for sure no it's definitely like
a staple out here and then like i think
it's dope because
it's like a fresh
persp like
you know coming from being a hip-hop fan
it's almost like it's some like
freestyle battle type [ __ ] but just on
stage like obviously we watched the
famous people
roast on comedy central which is
different this is like
two killers on stage
no holds barred term tiff just [ __ ]
going crazy tell em kids there was a guy
in a wheelchair yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
cerebral palsy yeah yeah the girl was
battling him yeah did not hold back she
said he looked like a [ __ ]
pterodactyl yeah dog because when you
have consent you you should be going
hard yeah you know i mean like all right
now we in here you know what i mean like
we all got consent in this [ __ ] it's a
nice that's a nice uh mantra to live by
fellas
i'm saying but when you have consent you
go hard okay listen listen i don't have
consent not to know mike tyson [ __ ] yeah
you know like on something like bill
cosby [ __ ] you know
you got to go softer you know we think
listen let's start
bill cosby's out of jail
my nigga's out
and i i saw that like he's thinking
about touring yeah but he's got to wait
for r kelly so they can do the best the
worst worlds tour and that'd be crazy it
would bro that would go up i'm not gonna
lie i always say this i love r kelly's
music i appreciate him as an artist yeah
i never was like a huge like i think i
grew up like a little bit past the cosby
show
so that wasn't like i was like right
before like my childhood so i really
never really cared about bill cosby
that's kind of like martin kelly's the
goat yeah that's kind of like me and oj
like i wasn't a fan before like i heard
about the murders and i was just like so
i know all i know is he killed this
white woman and then her boyfriend yeah
oh he remembered 2000 yards okay that's
cool yeah i wasn't watching [ __ ] usc
murder that season that shit's crazy no
but you think do you think bill cosby
could like do a successful stand-up tour
yeah like the chitlin circuit bring that
[ __ ] back you know what i mean like
people would like i think people would
pay to see him but do you think
promoters would book them or do you
think they'd be afraid of the outrage
black people are so forgiving they
support that dude i mean like listen
he's a monster i don't know what's to
happen but you know monsters have fans
too i bet if jeffrey dahmer was out
there or ted bunny were out there then
[ __ ] would have [ __ ] fans too
yeah i think it's crazy charles manson
have fans well you'll see people on
instagram that like act like what
happened with cosby getting out of jail
means that like he was redeemed and i'm
like no it was a it was a technicality
like he he was raping [ __ ]
yes he was kev
[Music]
but like depending on whose instagram
feed you follow because you know there's
like people who like swear like you know
yeah it's innocent these girls are lying
i'm like bro like
he got out of jail not because he was
innocent he got out of jail a
technicality
yeah that's crazy that's like yeah
that's that's like your killer yeah i
killed my sister and then you got out if
r kelly gets out though that'd be that'd
be uh
i would i would
i might go pay to see r kelly live i'm
not gonna lie yeah who's gonna produce
that album
i don't know man yeah but if bill cosby
and our kelly did somebody together bro
that [ __ ] would be crazy
stevie j producing the new arcade stevie
j quincy jones will come at retirement
you know what i mean all the greats it'd
be crazy no it's crazy um so you know
with i feel like we were just talking
off the camera a bit like yeah comedy to
me feels like at least in the stand-up
realm and podcasting and [ __ ] it feels
like the only
form of entertainment that we have
nowadays
in which like you can be
pretty much as uncut as possible without
worrying about hurting fear not
circumcised hell yeah yeah because like
you know when i was i was you know me
and my one of my one of my good friends
were just having a discussion about like
funny movies
and
i can't remember the last
comedy that came out
that was like
[ __ ] great
like it's been so long since we've had a
comedy that like and i'm not saying
there hasn't been funny movies mates
bridesmaids was i mean that was that was
one of those
girls trip
girls trip was good yeah um but as far i
mean i mean maybe that's it i mean like
yeah i mean like it's few and far
between like the last decade yeah i'm
just cause if you think about it like
they're like when we're growing up like
the biggest movies were always the like
funny movies like friday
even like 12 years ago the hangover
right that was another one yeah all the
will ferrell movies right right right
it's like what do we have now yeah you
don't really have that guy right now but
i mean like it's it takes a minute you
know it's kind of like u.s soccer
michael sarah's not really funniest
damn
kev's naming names no he's not funny i
don't care
they keep putting michael sarah in
[ __ ] movies like i'm supposed to i
mean by the way i love some michael
sarah movies yeah but but like you know
he became like a you like super bad you
like the rest of development super bad
was good so was the other one uh where
he fights all his ex
but i just mean like
who's that guy right now and i even seen
michael sarah years by the way i mean
like but who's the funny guy in movies
right now it's lil rel kevin hart i mean
you know kevin hart i'm not crazy about
his movies word i like his older
stand-ups it's a lot of excess he's
working i
understand on the movie tip because
kevin hart's movies are like they're
like like my kids can enjoy him
yeah it's evergreen you're always going
to see kevin hart yeah he's like he's
like a black steve steve gutenberg i
don't even know steve gutenberg yes
police academy movies see before my time
yeah before your time the police academy
come on born in 87. so when was sports
academy was popping in the 80s yeah like
when crack was hot
steve gutenberg was hot that's that
makes sense yeah everything comes back i
just remember as a child the police
academy i had the toys and there was the
guy who made the noises with his mouth
michael winslow yeah but
he still goes hard and low keys like was
like the first razell
[Music]
i think they might have been the same
time actually nah roselle was like the
whenever the roots were pop i remember
roselle was that [ __ ] though
yeah how about rossell's album as a kid
used at the warehouse it wasn't very
good he's starting like the 80s though
roselle i don't know okay shout out to
razer um but no i was just saying like i
just i just feel like you know obviously
there's almost like a renaissance of
like how big stand-up and comedians are
with how podcasting is going and kind of
like where
comedians fill the gap of what's missing
in mainstream entertainment these days
do you feel like it's like a great time
to be a comedian
this is the best time ever i'm i'm
excited i hate to i hate to say this but
it's like yeah when you have oppression
and like all this weird [ __ ] going on
like it can only create great art right
it can only inspire you to be like yo
[ __ ] is crazy let's talk about it before
we're all dead you know i mean before
another asteroid hiss this [ __ ] right
or before the aliens under the sea so i
can be like ah we got it you know what i
mean so this is the best time there's
there was black lives matter year last
year before that you had you know
everybody met at trump with me too and
then dak what they look like immigrants
right then you got this pandemic that
washed everything and now we're back to
the same [ __ ] really like everybody
leaned on that black lives matter and
all that other [ __ ] right it's not
really [ __ ] it gets into social
conscience but
[ __ ] we outside now and like the [ __ ]
didn't change right you know what i mean
especially in comedy it was like they
leaned heavy on it just to virtue signal
it and now it's like we're back outside
and it's like they're just yelling at
each other now you know and like nobody
can spit
nobody's spitting like dick gregory or
even you know patrice o'neill or even
like chappelle today or rock it's like
we're still leaning on chappelle to be
like give us the truth give us the truth
and it's like why is everybody else
giving us the truth you know what i mean
and i'm not going to name names got to
work with these casts but i like that
damon wayne's who's one of the who's one
of the greatest of all time is like yeah
i'll do a versus against dave chappelle
like that's the kind of energy you want
you want dudes who are like i can spit
and i'm going to show you i can spit
like i ain't dead yet [ __ ] as
richard pryor would say right or even
bernie mac it's like
it's not the same no more nobody's
afraid to get in trouble like that's
what makes the art great is like if
you're not afraid to say something
because we are you know the village
idiot right but we are kind of the voice
of reason too because we're bringing it
down so you can be like oh that's true
we should be better than that you know
what i mean yeah no i i love when i
obviously growing up damon wayne's just
like major pain was one of my favorite
movies ever and i was so glad to see it
like back on netflix and like in the top
10 i was like oh my god that means kids
are watching major page hell yeah
welcome back yeah yeah taliban back all
that [ __ ] about god it's great but no he
said taliban
everything's coming back the taliban hey
man right before that 20th uh season
what
merge drop
season 20 afghani afghani war merch drop
the easy edition
um who are the comedians though because
it's easier to name names when you're
giving them props so who are the
comedians now that you kind of look at
and you're like okay you're a dope
you're yo the next people coming up
right now man beth stelling can spit
jamar neighbors can [ __ ] spit andrew
santino spits
uh i mean there's a lot of precious hall
spits i mean we're talking about like
the next room was teddy ray spitz i just
saw yeah i saw andrew in phoenix and uh
he had he did a bit about the f word and
i was like i was like yes
yeah it's like ghost guess that yeah
those are the kind of casts that like
morgan murphy spits i mean like there's
there's people out there who are like
who are getting after it but you know
people are afraid to like say the wrong
thing and those the people i just named
are the most fearless people probably
doing it right now and i'm sorry if i
didn't name anybody i love out there
doing it that's why i mean
like you know i love uh i love tim
dillon so i don't agree with that that's
another one
yes exactly he's not a friend you give a
[ __ ] yes and then when he gets in
trouble he just leans into it
yeah like you really gonna shoot me you
know what i mean it's like he's yeah
no i think um i just think that like
it's been dope to see kind of just the
evolution of where comedy's gone and how
like every comedian
that's dope is having a moment with
podcasting like bill burr's podcast it's
[ __ ] amazing right it's just like a
whole nother way to consume like what's
missing because you can't go to the
theater and like obviously there's some
shows like i love dave on
fx there's like some funny shows still i
just um subscribe to bt plus to to check
out yo look at you for the culture
that lady is so funny miss pat is saying
yeah
dude
she's miss pad
yeah miss pat's a monster she's [ __ ]
hilarious yeah yeah she's pissed and she
don't care about nobody yeah that woman
don't give a [ __ ] about nobody i know
everybody please and i just hit play on
that [ __ ] me and my wife are dying bro
yeah and now she's the truth yeah she
just she was just on rogan yeah that's
where i i saw her before on rogan a
couple like maybe a year or two ago and
but i was like uh
i didn't know she had a sitcom so i was
just bored and i think first season of
uh roosevelt on comedy central she was
on our thing yeah she said yeah they're
like you guys got to see this woman yeah
we got we went to chicago just to go
just to go be around her and she i mean
man you talk about nobody give a [ __ ]
and she battle ralphy mate too before
mike lawrence did wow yeah that's season
one she's yeah she's a beast shout out
to ralphie may r p all right rp man um
how how are you kind of like for your
brand and where you're at like like how
like the pandemic happened obviously
kind of switched up everyone's take like
i think uh andrew scholes kind of showed
people like a way of like doing comedy a
whole different way and still kind of
keeping your integrity bro yeah he's
he's the moses right now that [ __ ] he's
leading us it's like all right that's
how you that's how you get down and it's
and it's not corny you know what you
know that's what i'm saying he kept his
integrity because yeah it's not my space
dan cook [ __ ] right you know what i mean
it's not
it's not shots fire yeah shots
it's not jonas brothers my space [ __ ]
it's like it's not like it's like oh
that's how you do it i'm with that it's
like mixtape [ __ ] it's like he's passing
out mixtapes out of his trunk but on the
internet you know it's like it's hip hop
it's punk rock i'm like you get down
with schultz because of that and he's
not afraid to say [ __ ] that's facts um
but like for you personally how have you
kind of like
uh
has it like like the last year and some
change has it kind of made you look at
things differently or pivot in a certain
way [ __ ] yes
because all it has done is it's
separated
fake you know it separates the uh the
fake from the other from the real ones
like you really get to see who your real
ones are you know what i mean like i'm
assuming everyone's circle got smaller
because obviously because of covet but
then you're like you really got to see
everybody's character you know like
especially when he came back outside it
was like oh you [ __ ] didn't really
give a [ __ ] he was just saying it for
the clout so
especially with the black lives matter
[ __ ] negro there's literally a george
floyd moment happening right now with
this vaccine how easy is it to be at
home uh where you can't leave your house
and post a black square
that was my interest i'm joking like
what else are you gonna do yeah
it's like you can't do [ __ ] about it no
what i'm saying like of course you're
gonna post a black square because
otherwise you're an [ __ ] but what
happens when things are actually open
and you know you guys yeah i don't know
man it's just yeah like yeah with the
vaccine thing we're talking about that
[ __ ] offline too it's like
it's 72 percent of the black people they
said like a couple weeks ago on the cdc
weren't getting vaccinated and all i
kept hearing was just you know white
comics on twitter just yell at people
the to shut the [ __ ] up and get the
vaccine and like they have some
outrageous [ __ ] sometimes like i saw a
dude who had posted is like we need to
hog tie people ain't vaccinated take him
down to jail and bring out the the
non-violent offender i'm like
what
are we talking about
what are we talking about so it's like
at this point i'm like this is this is a
george floyd moment like i was just
saying a second ago where like the
medical community has kneeled on the
necks of black people for [ __ ]
centuries and now everybody must be like
hey can you throw that [ __ ] aside so we
can get back to live now you want to
trust us thank you it's just like what
about black lives matter what about you
know like my issues like i don't trust
these [ __ ] you know like i have
ptsd with this [ __ ] and you guys are
like
yeah but we can't get back to work and
like do like what we used to do which is
like dominate the country so could you
yeah i was talking to glasses malone and
he was kind of saying the same thing
like he's like i think everyone should
get vaccinated he's like but
the reason why
my community is is not rushing to get
vaccinated because the medical industry
has [ __ ] this over for
ever yeah so now we're just supposed to
yeah just trust what what they want to
put in our body i mean that's what i'm
saying it's like free by the way they're
just like oh you're dying three times
more we're like well nick has been dying
bro like where the money yet right
like that's it and if we're gonna talk
about you know california in general you
know latinos aren't getting vaccinated
either like glasses is talking about
because like listen a lot of people that
live in those homes like you know they
may have an illegal family member right
last thing he wants to do is go put his
name in a system next thing like you
know six months later ice is knocking on
your door like there goes your home
depot there goes your produce there goes
your [ __ ] 6 a.m leaf blower in the
morning it's just like
bro what are we talking about here
getting these digital mandating digital
vax cards for communities that don't
trust the medical community like
what are we talking about
yeah i think i'm vaccinated everybody
should get back i'm vaccinated too you
know but no i i think that everyone
when you start mandating certain [ __ ]
and like obviously there's always been a
certain level of
if you have a kid and they go to school
they have to have a certain amount of
shots or whatever to go to go to school
right whether it's their flu shot or
their chicken pox whatever the [ __ ] it
is
but i think that like
it's not fda approved
that's not selling my wife last night
and my wife was she's like i don't give
a [ __ ] and i'm like she's like you know
the fda
has [ __ ] over so many people with the
food they approve but at the same time
like yeah it's not fda approved so how
can you force people to get something
that's not even approved by the fda
right but i mean not to say that fda is
like they've done this with vaccines
before i mean like i i mean just history
has shown that that that's not what
scares me about it like because
obviously the fda like you just said
like how do you trust them anyway i'm
just saying like they've done this
before with emergency submissions what
i'm saying is uh i mean cope is in it's
like sophomore junior season you know
what i mean like
copenhagen had like a like a giannis
year you know what i mean but it's like
you know it ain't like it ain't aids it
ain't you know it ain't the flu the
food's bill russell and
i guess aids is like it's like lebron
because it still puts up numbers and
it's like 40 years old that's so crazy a
million a year aids is like lebron yeah
i'm hearing like with aids though it's
like a lot easier now to live oh bro
yeah
yeah
i think everybody knows like somebody
with hiv you know like that's still like
they just gotta crack
yeah out here [ __ ] still still doing
this [ __ ] yeah i mean magic johnson
facts he's the guy he's the guy he's the
goat yeah um no i so you got vaccined
yeah did you get vaccine because you're
just like i'm just making it
yes i wanted to work in the industries
though i had to do it because you know
sag is you know sag is requiring it the
wga is requiring it right if you go
inside your performer they're requiring
it and there's no wiggle room because
they don't listen restaurants bars
nightclubs all these they were close
like 18 months they're like we're going
to comply with whatever they want
because otherwise we're going to lose
their [ __ ] business like i don't give
a [ __ ] if like you can't come to my
building so now it feels like if you're
a performer feels like you're like back
in i don't know the 40s performing like
hey look at all these white people
because [ __ ] ain't getting vaccinated
you know what i mean latinos getting
vaccinated and you're like
did you see the uh arkansas drug dealer
commercial for the bro did i see that
like what i'd be out here hustling so i
had to get back i'd be out here selling
things yeah yeah you know i can't risk
contracting cover 19.
i said oh my god as he puts putting on
him there's no way that guy was an actor
otherwise he's a great actor get him out
of arkansas move him to california and
give him a job i'm not restricting him
from being a great actor he actually
might be one because he killed it yeah
he's like oh this [ __ ]
yeah no he's not my next season between
that and the facts that thing up
juvenile remix i was like yo who the
[ __ ]
this is like
pandering at its worst yeah
like are they supposed to think black
people are gonna see juvenile sing vax
that ass up and run to get a [ __ ] jab
if you ain't vote for buying you ain't
black so you know that's where the
marketing dollars are going
please get vaccinated wait your drug
dealers are getting vaccinated your
favorite rappers are getting vaccinated
please
who's i want to know whose favorite
rapper is juvenile in 2021 like i want
to know taliban [ __ ] they back
hey that afghanistan [ __ ] is crazy it
really is it's gonna go brazil he's
gonna go crazy he's going to go all of
them it's crazy because i see like both
sides of the of of the argument where
it's like yo there was this is
unwinnable
no matter when we pulled out this was
going to happen
uh all right so like yeah but but mine's
always gonna get this [ __ ] pregnant but
my thing is like
we went there so i feel like we oh
as much as i when
you know joe biden said yesterday that
uh
how are we supposed to stay there and
fight a fight that they're not even
willing to fight because their army is
obviously [ __ ] because they just was
like we out
president-elect it was just a job for
them you know mercenaries we also went
there and [ __ ] up their whole [ __ ] but
we spent like
they said trillions yeah like in 20
years they like build infrastructure
tons of people have died
and i think like
at least to the people there like we
should we i feel like
you know we owe them something
at least like we you know and i know it
might cost taxpayers money but i'm like
bro we kind of like came through and
[ __ ] up their i mean i was saying we
[ __ ] up their whole country
but we've been there for 20 years so
there's 19 year old females that are
don't know no other life but all right
half-assed
democracy so it's like and we're just
gonna just be like
all right y'all figure this [ __ ] out
well this is this it's the same
difference of like if we would have
fought the cartels you know down in
mexico forever or down in like you know
south america forever it's like it would
have been the same thing they were going
to wait it out and then like because
like this ain't going nowhere player you
know i mean like this poppy feels out
here there's drug money out here you
know i mean like and these guys are more
about these guys a little more religious
and spiritual
but it's not the thing to stop doing
that [ __ ]
yeah they had time to wait and they were
like nah we are going to be here forever
and you're going to spend that money and
we're still going to be here
and we're ants
and then we just like bounce and left
all of our weapons and [ __ ] so they got
all our guns no it's crazy we ain't
getting our security deposit but i just
feel bad for all those people because
i'm like man like they they're ha they
had to like you would you would like to
think that they could have set up some
sort of
way to get out of there where they they
you know maybe it was gradually slower
and you know there was like a way to
apply to come to america if you live
there
this is like a new nom right like a new
name a new vietnam it's like that's what
they're saying they compared it to
saigon damn yeah i saw the pictures
there though it was way quicker it
happened way quicker than saigon yeah no
it was like uh what that uh baltimore
colts thing when they went to
indianapolis they did [ __ ] like the
middle of the night and just bounced
just dip like all right we out man y'all
are [ __ ] yeah
that video is crazy though the video of
the the airplane that [ __ ] is crazy
that situation's crazy the whole thing
is crazy
i saw today the taliban put out some
letter to like all the local political
officials saying that they need lists of
all females that are widowed under 45 or
uh females that are over the age of 15
to be married to taliban fighters
like what the [ __ ] yeah man imagine
you're 17 years old and you only know
this americanized version of afghanistan
and then all of a sudden you got to go
marry some [ __ ] well now your
lifestyle is going to be death to all
infidels death to america so crazy i
don't know how many people are in
afghanistan but like if that's your
government right now that that's what
the kids are going to be taught for
center you know for generations and
centuries
we're going to deal with that forever
because there is a lot of anti-america
propaganda in that area as there should
be so you know that's like if you know
you you go to like somebody's house and
just beat the [ __ ] up all the time
you're like all right we out man you're
like all right all right i'm gonna get
all my [ __ ]
i mean so and for centuries so yeah this
is not gonna work out it was never going
to work out yeah it's wild man it's
unfortunate but you know it is what it
is
uh
you know listen that's what i'll say
i obviously voted for joe biden despite
him being a flaming piece of dog [ __ ]
um
he's not as
i still stand by the fact that i would
rather have joe biden as my president of
donald trump yeah but that doesn't mean
joe biden is
i'm just saying i mean like this whole
al qaeda league it's like we had isis
you know last what last decade and [ __ ]
like we're still banging isis records
likely to go back to the we had to go
back to back that ass up with the
taliban and [ __ ] taliban is the og they
back now it's just like all right man
like taliban's having like the naz kings
disease moment yeah
they really are yeah
they're coming back and winning the
grammy oh the locks in the verses
oh my god you know what i mean so like
yeah taliban's back
did you watch that who didn't watch that
kev i don't know some people young
gorgeous that was the best [ __ ] ever man
are you kidding me i've rewatched it
like three times you already watched i
rewatched it last night oh [ __ ] i was
just [ __ ] like doing some work on my
laptop and i had that [ __ ] playing and
i'm just like [ __ ] kisses so fire
yeah i felt really i didn't feel bad for
a dip set i feel bad for everyone who
just kind of like thought that they were
gonna just win and and like on surface
it'd be easy to say
dipset will win
but like they weren't as good performers
and then like and they don't like each
other
they're not hanging out anymore no
they're not
like the locks are still with each other
yeah like you know what i'm saying like
they've been putting out eps they
so
yeah and then what kiss was saying was
some real [ __ ] we're in new york stop
rhyming over your records hey like kids
like clue right yeah
yeah
man kisses like like the kids write all
of hip-hop i mean like what is that
that's the goat bro geez yeah no i
thought that was a the battle was the
best verses in my opinion was either
that one or the gucci gz one because i
actually thought someone might come out
of that not breathing um but the lot for
me the locks
and dip set was
it was just like
it it it it to me it brought people back
to why i loved hip hop and i feel like
that's gone i mean obviously we're
friends with fred we're you know the
griselda guys are doing their thing but
on a grand scale an extremely mainstream
scale like
why we all love hip hop growing up in
the 90s was on display in full force
yeah
yeah it was the uh the anti-hate the
baby concert you know what i mean like
nah we love that [ __ ] yeah bring it in
here and it was like celebrated and it
was dope you know it was like this is a
cultural thing
shout out to the baby shout out to the
baby shoot yeah that was a while ago i
know he's watching what's up man did you
um did you when you saw what the thing
happened with the babe and you kept
doubling down and tripling down like
man unnecessary unnecessary it's not
necessary you think it's like you're
going out of your way to be like [ __ ]
y'all right right right just like all
right sorry and then like you know move
on you know what i mean like yeah yeah
like yeah it's like outsmart you know
whatever you think the bad guy is you
know yeah it's not like he's like a like
boosie right boozy can say whatever the
[ __ ] he wants and it literally doesn't
matter boozy's not a pop star he's a
cultural icon in certain parts of the
country yeah he's like forever good
right the babies like at the moment well
at that moment had more spotify
listeners than drake
damn
he put up drake numbers on spotify he
had more monthly listeners than any male
rapper at the time damn so you're like
in a different
stratosphere there's different bags yeah
it's like you know what's chris brown
did or something you know what i mean i
mean he didn't beat the [ __ ] out of me
no i'm not safe i'm not saying that i'm
just saying like that hurt chris's
streams didn't it
i mean
i don't know shout out to chris brown i
would say we were talking about they
were like man if chris brown could come
back from beating the [ __ ] out of
rihanna
then the baby got to be able to come
back but then again
chris brown didn't [ __ ] up rihanna in
2021 word
chris brown if that happened in 2021
chris brown would forever be exiled
true facts yeah yeah you can't do that
in 2021 it happened in 09 and then he
went on al or was it no larry king he
went on larry king he had his you know
and then
but that ain't happening for if you a
man that's why it's with tory lanez
depending on what happens with the with
the megan story
if he really shot her in the feats
man it's gonna be tough i mean you
shouldn't be shooting nobody but i'm
saying but like shooting a black woman
i mean
who's the superstar and then putting an
album out he put an album out yeah
the day the brianna taylor verdict came
in
he put an album out that same day
where the whole album was about that
incident
i'm like bro you got to read the room
sometimes with the baby's like bro
sometimes you got to read the room right
right right like yeah you like you can
just chill yeah you can just chill i
mean like art award that [ __ ] you know i
mean like look at you whoever you think
the enemy is whether that's good or bad
or right or wrong just like you just got
to study you just got to study them
are you um because you know obviously
with canceled culture being like such a
big deal in today's world
um yeah
on the comedian culture's the homie by
the way so shout out to the cancer
culture right it's wild it's crazy
because there's certain there's certain
[ __ ] i'm like yeah get them the [ __ ] out
of here but then there's other [ __ ]
where you'll see and you'll be like guys
really
right i mean like yes and obviously yeah
the people who are getting canceled
should be for the most part for the most
part yeah like of course like the uh
what's his name the [ __ ] fat [ __ ] who
looks like uh jeff garland
uh
the movie guy
what the [ __ ] the guy who started the
metoo movement what's up oh weinstein
why is he watching yeah
get him the [ __ ] out of here yeah yeah
yeah
right but
i mean you know then there's like matt
damon
volunteers information in an interview
that he'd barely just stop saying the f
word right
bad move on his part because why would
you say that like why would you just
throw but at the same time necessary
but necessary at the same time right
obviously
he's not a hateful guy who's homophobic
right
and there's like there was like a whole
twitter storm about like getting matt
damon the [ __ ] out of here because he
barely just stopped saying that word and
i'm like guys like come on man
yeah but twitter's like you know those
agents in the matrix like they're not
your friend
and it's a very like weird
underbelly of the population who's like
on twitter all day waiting to be angry
yeah and it ain't the middle of the
country it's true yeah i mean yeah it
ain't android users
i got both man you know i got bo you
have two phones okay i can't let go of
the android man something about the
android trap phone yeah i mean this beat
the [ __ ] though
i still got my i got my iphone but i
can't let go of that i can't let go of
the android man i love kev bro like
kevin's kind of got you running the
party and you're like oh yeah that guy's
from phoenix i get it thanks yeah dog
i'm taking that as a
non-compliment that's a compliment it's
a backhanded one but it's a compliment
it's a pretty backhand yeah we out here
yeah i'm the rose battle guy
anyway
um nah but yeah i just think like uh
we're just in a weird place in the
society man where i you know
like you said like we're we're talking
off the air about uh
andrew scholes and like he's like like
or just people in general who have
a fan base
that decides whether or not
joe rogan right
joe rogan they try to cancel joe rogan
once a month it feels like yeah he's got
influence but you can't but you can't
cancel somebody be that that that isn't
officially and he's officially tied to
spotify for the record but
you know who really isn't like really
officially tied to like
a big corporation where it's like hey
you're uh nah we're taking like nick
cannon right they took wilin out off
right right away right
and that and nick cannon is
a brilliant guy
under rated i mean people don't give
nick cannon enough credit for
knowing talent uh presenting talent and
giving talent so much so many
opportunities like you know he went he's
gone through a couple things a couple
incidences right like having kevin
hart's back about the lgbtq thing and
then the uh the anti-semitism of it all
but um man i mean nick
listen nick just he just he he wants to
be in the culture so bad help the
culture so bad so it's like when he was
like you know siding with the the desean
jacksons of the world and steven you
know the stephen jacksons of the world
the jacksons you know he got in trouble
but then it was like he took it upon
himself to to learn right like he didn't
debate it he didn't double down for a
second right and then you know it was
just like yo bro like you might be in
the wrong he's like all right if i'm
hurting this many people i gotta maybe
maybe i need to talk to somebody yeah he
took some therapy tools and like really
got after it so and then again like he's
put so many people on you wouldn't even
think about so no nick cannon is a goat
and my first writing job you know i mean
so like shout out nick i think nick
cannon not only on the on the comedy
side but on the artist side like like he
found kailani i didn't know that he
found her okay
her was signed to nick cannon first she
was a kid
good for him kailani was signing the
cannon first right
nick cannon is very in inspires me
because he has
he's so good at so many things
and like
it it you know when i when i think like
damn my plate is so full i got so much
[ __ ] going on i look at a guy like nick
cannon i'm like man what is his life
like this [ __ ] just has like 11
children and he's hosting a goddamn mass
singer he's doing a radio show every day
he's [ __ ] starting his own [ __ ]
daily t i'm like man [ __ ] like
that man really just like he fires me
he's he's the underground like you know
russell simmons like he's but he's like
above ground which is crazy
he's very commercially viable but at the
same time like some somehow
underappreciated exactly yeah i'm like i
appreciate them thanks nick shout out so
he gave you your first writing job yeah
wrote a while now to like season eight
or something like that so that was like
my first you know like like writing job
for tv yeah nick uh wilding out is like
a another show that at least in the uh
at least in my opinion and you're more
in the commit community than i am but in
the in the comedy community feels like
it doesn't get enough love
yeah i mean listen man it's competitive
down here you know it's like rap you
know like if if anybody smells you know
corniness in the water they're going to
attack it it's like a pure like you said
it's kind of like i mean there's a bit
of the roast battle elements to it but
it's it's it's like a comedy show like
and it's beautiful
almost dope yeah i think it's great
especially like you know when you're in
there you're like oh these are like the
harlem globetrotters of comedy like
these are the best and like they don't
you have that you go through a test
and you know like i've been on like you
know i've been in the foot you know like
like changing ninja turtle [ __ ] like
i've seen i've seen some [ __ ] in there
bro they
they go hard with the comedy [ __ ] it's
like it's some navy seal [ __ ] who's some
of your favorite people who've come out
of that show carlos miller chico bean dc
young fly i mean just to name those
three off top because they're the illest
uh diesel mirror we're on that season i
wrote on uh what's the white girl's name
justina valentine's [ __ ] great she's
ill she can see it yeah she can remember
corey sharon can spit he's been on there
uh jacob williams is funny uh kevin
hart's funny uh got cory holcomb's funny
you know what i mean
uh kat williams is funny pete davidson
mikey day taran killum so when you do
writing for a show like because you've
written for other shows right mm-hmm
what is the
like you know cause for people who don't
know uh surprise most of these all these
late night shows have writers got to
yeah they have to so when you're writing
for like let's say you're writing for a
while now are you helping write some of
the punch lines are you like what are
you what are you bringing to the team
what you're bringing is you're bringing
ammo like they may never use anything
you're gonna write right but you're just
bringing ammo you're just bringing like
all right cool we got guns we got
weapons right but they can need ammo
yeah i mean so you're just filling up
your ammo like they would they they get
inspired or they may use your jokes
right so the way i get down is like i go
as hard as possible so you can tell me
to scale back i'm never gonna be like i
hope the network likes this i want to
know what the i want to get in the
network space and be like this is what
we're saying they're like okay cool
don't say that you know maybe
try something else here because we don't
know if we can get this across to the
sponsors and the people who pay our
bills right like that's their fight we
don't want to get fired that's everybody
in hollywood by the way everybody that's
why things don't get made you wonder why
things get made when you write [ __ ] or
you turn anything like they bought this
and you're like eight years later you're
like you know i sold the script right
it's because like everyone's trying to
like dump your [ __ ] down enough toy they
don't get fired they're like you know
because we sell [ __ ] to china now so
it's like especially
you know films and tv shows it's like
we don't want to get you know we don't
lose that money this is capitalism baby
you got to throw john cena on that
drop that yeah in in mandarin chinese
put some more water in there take some
salt out you know what i mean take some
sugar out you think that that's a big
reason too why like movies have sucked
or not been like crazy because bro
everybody's afraid to lose their job
this way everything's been done to death
because they know it works
why don't like i mean has this i mean
behind the scenes has this ever been
something talked about where like a lot
of these like comedians who have bigfoot
i'm ready to talk about it i'm together
and put a movie out yeah where it's
starring like a bunch of dope comedians
who have followings yeah you seen harlow
knights nah thank you that was like uh
prior and uh oh yeah harlem i thought
you said old school [ __ ] like life you
know what i mean that was another one
that's like yeah cass used to put each
other on like people could all just pull
together and independently produce an
amazing movie yeah and like it'll do
well because everyone has followings i
got the hookup right master p did that
[ __ ] that was a great movie you know
like we should be doing that [ __ ] we
should be selling the booklet style
bootleg cabs yeah nah i always wanted
because that's what i like about the
dudes who do workaholics right
they just made their own movie and they
put it on netflix uh what was that movie
called cook
where they're like [ __ ] they're
working at the hotel and like people try
to take the hotel over and i was like
damn why don't like [ __ ] like
you know
five or six of the biggest comedians
come together and run yeah
[ __ ] bill bill burr
rogan
you know shoals
uh the guys from 85 south like
yo put up like do your own [ __ ] moves
that'd be crazy bring all these worlds
together yeah
yeah just have rogan he don't even be in
it just pay for it right
have spotify pay for it yeah spotify
maybe yeah
i mean i don't know
you know people got to act too you know
everybody can't act
people can be fearless but you know it
doesn't mean that everybody can act yeah
that's fair yeah and you know like you
know
some people can't read so
that's fair hey interrupting the
interview to tell you about our good
friends at odd socks now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying oh shout out to my
bony ass knees um listen go to
oddssocksofficial.com they got all the
craziest socks these are the outsiders
you know what i'm saying they got
spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you
these are chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20 off of of your order
underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
heaven checkout save twenty percent i
just had an argument with my girl about
bad actors because she thinks uh paul
walker was a good actor rest in peace
shout out paul walker bro i'll tell you
a story about paul walker if you're
talking about your wife
oh no she was just like telling me how
like he's like one of her favorite
actors i'm like no you just like the way
he looks like he can't act yeah i'm not
to say he can't act but he wasn't like a
great actor i love paul walker no i love
i mean i have a bias so i mean i think
he could do it wrong do you ever watch
the movie running scared yeah i did
because paul walker was in it's his best
movie
that [ __ ] is so dark and twisted and
crazy with that being said i mean he's
you know him and vin diesel are like you
know they're trading on like who's the
worst actor
paul walker god bless him rest in peace
i just didn't think he was like i liked
his movies but it doesn't mean he's a
good actor tyrus is worse than paul
walker and uh fast and furious too yeah
you're right tyree's a bad actor yeah i
mean i wouldn't say i mean in that movie
in these movies he is but it seems like
everybody gets in those movies and they
become bad actors it's weird even like
directors who who are great like john
singleton who's the other guy i think
john woo or something like that angley
one of them did one of those fast and
furious i know john singleton did the
second one you're like oh this is just
not this is not the part to them what's
your personal bias with paul walker no i
love him so uh i remember i come from
like the sticks i come from like not
like suburbs or the hood i come from
like
nasty parts of like california like the
high desert of california oh hi desert
yeah so like where though like past
riverside pass bar stuff like i mean i'm
driving racecrest ridge cruise i drive
down the lake i drive through all that
[ __ ] to go to phoenix oh that's that's
the bot that's the low [ __ ] we're going
through like
yeah i'm like if you're going towards
like mammoth mountain type [ __ ]
so what's the high is the high desert
like a mojave desert yeah is that like
on the way to vegas like through
lancaster and [ __ ] yeah it's no it seems
like a hundred mile yeah it's even like
50 to 60 miles from mail lancaster and
yeah yeah yeah no that's where palmdale
george that's like
yeah like when i was driving like
there's certain parts like when you
drive to vegas the back way oh yeah
you'll be like this is some hills have i
[ __ ] oh dawg that's where i'm from
my homie lives in apple valley and that
[ __ ] is wild enough yeah yeah yeah i'm
in even worse i ain't in the uh you're
from a very interesting part of we
played we played that's where you know
keith stanfield he's from like asparagus
in that area apple valley so like for
high school we would play those cats
like that's but it would be like a 45 an
hour ride just going through the desert
it's gross yeah but uh this uh this
chick i was talking to when i was like
in like eighth or seventh grade and i
think paul walker had done varsity blues
or running scared or something
and uh she was like cause we you know
it's back when phones were a thing of
course and like a homegirl hooked us up
like y'all call my homegirl and then uh
she's like you sound like paul walker
and i was like oh
you're gonna be surprised and so ever
since then i was just like yeah he's
like a white dude but like a paul walker
white dude i'm like all right i'll go
with that and he's like you know he's
like all-american-looking so i'll go
with that i love you paul walker thank
you
man
he passed away in santa clarita right
was it santa clarita was it yeah i think
magic mountain way up there was over
there racing in santa clarita damn or
whatever wherever it was r.i.p with that
being said
i did not see the new fast and the
furious i haven't watched one since five
really yeah you stopped at five you
dropped out yeah it's like police
academy just whatever one was the first
movie the rock was in after that i was
like all right guys
they're going forever this is how you
build generational wealth kev i will
watch if they bring jurassic park and
fast and furious together yeah like
they've been talking about like i'll
watch that because i want to see that
level of [ __ ] wait what yeah they're
talking they've been talking about this
is real
thank you
they're talking about making a jurassic
park and fast and furious um like the
world's coming together and somehow
intertwining for like a mega movie no i
need aliens predators and jurassic park
like what is that first of all cars i
get it you're metal weapons but you're
not dinosaurs right you're not an alien
you're not you know what i mean like
yeah [ __ ] chris pratt and vin diesel
like we're gonna find out chris pratt's
like vin diesel's like third cousin
dinosaurs i got a car for that
yeah no dinosaurs have too much like
generational trauma that's why they're
so mean
i mean yo i'm not gonna lie i was in
florida
like a few weeks ago
and i was looking at an alligator at
busch gardens in tampa and i was like
that's a dinosaur yeah dog
that's a [ __ ] dinosaur yeah i can't
say [ __ ] alligators are dinosaurs bro
yeah that's a real ass dinosaur you know
the oldest shark's like 300 years old
i just saw somebody on instagram yeah
post a a video of oh i follow a lot of
those like uh
like animal
people yeah like tarzan and there's like
this other guy tarzan
tarzan
i mean like what tarzan and james
black dude who's like oh no he's like
hanging out with like snakes and [ __ ]
he's popping his [ __ ] on his head so i
follow like a million of those kind of
people who and yeah there's some guy
found this shark that's like one of the
or i don't even know if it's a shark
it's like a supposed to be like one of
the oldest animals left on earth and it
looks like a [ __ ] dinosaur but it's
in the water it's in the everglades i
mean how they gonna know that they've
only they've only discovered or charted
five percent of the ocean i mean like we
don't know you said something earlier
about aliens coming out of the ocean
yeah i think that's the place that's
what yeah first of all it's hard to get
here from outer space you know what i
mean like what we're talking about here
we don't know that we don't know what
space is well did you see the video that
came out yeah where there was uh it was
like a navy video and it showed like a
the like unidentified and it just went
straight into the water yeah dude i'm
saying there's we've only discovered
five percent of the ocean at this point
like
they're coming from the bottom trip this
true story yeah
my grandma's sister's husband yeah
his name's uh doc is dead now was one of
the original
nasa scientists okay
my mom went and visited them like 20
years ago or some [ __ ] yeah hidden
figures they live in maryland
and uh my mom asked him
if aliens were real okay
he said he couldn't answer the question
what year was she asked him it's
probably in the 90s okay so you were
alive i was alive okay um and she and he
but she he told her
i can't answer that question but if
people knew what was in the ocean they'd
want to kill themselves
[Laughter]
and i i heard my mom told me this like
when i was like i don't know 10 11 or
something and i was like damn that [ __ ]
always stuck with me and uh you know he
passed away but he was like
oh gee nasa oh gee nasa yeah oh geez
damn so how crazy bro so every time i
see some ocean [ __ ] i'm like man
the ocean got some [ __ ] in it ocean got
some [ __ ] bro
i mean like we should be talking to
animals we should be talking to animals
and stop worrying about this other [ __ ]
so we can [ __ ] fight the aliens that
are coming from the bottom of the ocean
real talk i think they're already here
man no they've been here yeah yeah
they've been here like you saw the new
uh suicide squad they've been here the
suicide squad movies fire
that's a good movie
better than the first one
it was better than the first one but
that's the bar we're going off of it's
like ain't no bars that was a yeah it
was not an alien [ __ ] man the music we
gonna see and i feel like that they're
they're they picked the perfect time to
start like kind of we're so worried
about covid and all this other [ __ ]
going on they've been kind of like
throwing us little like yeah water
people i mean like come on they're
throwing us little [ __ ] tidbits like
obama's saying that ufos are real and
the cia is not people ain't even really
painted i mean people are paying
attention because it's made like
headlines but it's not like people are
so worried about everything else yeah
soon i think in the next like 10 years
we gonna know
i mean i don't know i that's crazy i
mean hopefully not just jeff bezos is
over here [ __ ] he's trying to get
away yeah there's you know something bro
they're paying uh they just put this
thing out uh where nasa's about to pay
like 50 people
they're simulating mars oh no on earth
and they're going to pay like 50 people
to live in this mars simulation for like
a year so these guys can get the data
and then you know figure out yeah how
can we live over there and start a new
population because once these aliens pop
out the [ __ ] ocean yeah we're gonna
have to leave the planet i mean right
now those you know all this craziness
happening right with like you know this
new super bug and all you know all the
[ __ ] we had the previous years that's
like yeah why wouldn't they come out now
like all right these [ __ ] ain't
looking let's go get them that's crazy
i would think uh the first person i
think is like a real elon musk's got to
have some sort of
he strikes me as like
an alien like if someone were like be
like yo elon musk was an alien
you wouldn't trip
yeah it makes sense that's cool yeah
his wife gonna drop that new album
what's up yeah he's cool i mean i guess
whatever
what do you um you know being a a
comedian during the trump presidency had
to be
scary and awesome because there's like a
ton of material but at the same time a
really scary dude to be running the
country
like how how did you kind of like like
you know i always feel like when we have
like these crazy presidents like even
when jor like george w bush when he was
president the snl skits were funnier
like right right they had a target they
had a big target with trump it was just
like oh my god this is crazy like this
it was almost like we were watching the
simpsons every day on cnn yeah but you
could equate that to like the rose
battle [ __ ] you saw you know like if you
have a bigger target you got more jokes
you know i mean like in truck trump made
himself a you know inflatable basically
almost like a macy state parade you know
balloon like even in england they had
like the the baby trump you know what i
mean with the big ass head and [ __ ] so
like trump was doing so many things that
were sparking and creating inspiration
because it's like all right we can nail
them there we can nail them there we can
nail them there's just a lot of
low-hanging fruit with that cat so much
yeah and people like to eat mike pence
is like also like it's another cat very
like i just i mean it was it was an
interesting time he's whatever
yeah i couldn't stand trump bro but
right now is even better i mean like
there's so much [ __ ] going on so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on it's like this is the
time i this is this is when you get it
the 20s it's like the beginning of the
century it's there's so much crazy [ __ ]
going on you know post trump right post
you know being locked up in the house
kind of a thing we out and it's still
pandemic season so people don't give
[ __ ] bro it's crazy you know shootings
went up like 50 in l.a
right even more in south l.a robberies
yeah no melrose is high all that [ __ ]
people yeah the k yeah the catalytic
conversions are getting stolen like
crazy like 200 they're saying l.a times
what yeah well i know catalina
converters getting stolen was a thing
but it's like that that's like a thing
thing my homeboy got us thrown twice
twice you got to be a real dedicated ass
crackhead to hop under a whip and on it
i mean they also all the convicts though
you know i mean like during the
pandemics they didn't want to kill him
i think to the homeless people out here
that's probably an easy lick for them
yeah no i mean if you get out of jail
that's an easy look for you caliber
converter yeah because you're nonviolent
offender who's getting now it's like for
the most part those are just car thieves
right right you know what i mean like
it's that's not violent it's just like
yeah
during the pandemic i feel like has has
um
gotten interesting man because obviously
the homeless [ __ ] has gone out of
control
it's always been a thing it's new gotham
city yeah
but now it's like no matter where you're
at
except burbank shout out to burbank i
love burbank because i live there and i
don't see any homeless people it's kind
of wild
it's like a [ __ ] uh
y'all y'all do the most stringent cops
right now i think it's because burbank
has his own police force yeah and y'all
don't play that [ __ ] [ __ ] the armenians
don't [ __ ] play they really don't
yeah i only get pulled over here i feel
like now but
everywhere there's [ __ ] this homeless
[ __ ] is crazy like
on top of that the like man i always
tell everybody i'm like man like anybody
who comes to town they always are trying
to go to melrose and go shopping and all
you know i'll talk to my rapper homies
and i just try to tell them like bro i'm
gonna go to melrose why am i gonna say
his name but like a close friend of mine
got robbed um coming out of
one of those rash i think it might have
been catcher one of them damn coming out
of the catch i live right there a
gangster a gangster rapper what yeah
all his jewelry got robbed
and
you know i try to tell these cats bro
they'd be out there he you know kev i
think people forgot this too like kids
are in the house right and like
the dropout rate in la for like
african-american kids right because the
gang culture's so big here like them
kids hit the formative years and they
they trying to get the stripes and
people forgot we kept those kids in the
house so like who's gonna enforce going
to school you're on zoom a lot of them
even got the internet so they're just
like [ __ ] it i'm out or like a laptop to
be on the internet you know what i mean
they're like i'm gonna be on my phone
all day you know
even my my car got hit yeah i had
someone follow me out of the bank
and uh this was in june of last year
yeah i took out like 15 grand in cash
bro they hit my car
hit a [ __ ] i was i i was out of my car
for maybe a minute and a half busted out
my window took my bag and hit a 50. kids
are out and they are yeah bro it's gang
gang everywhere these kids aren't going
to school right now what do you do you
think that there's even any because
you know with the homeless thing you
would almost feel like it's so out of
control that like there's really no
solution to it that's easy at least that
makes sense that's just going to hurt
people's feelings i mean like honestly
you just got to sweep all that [ __ ] and
just hey you can't sleep on the sidewalk
there's no camping here you know what i
mean like
go for you know i i don't say anything
too harsh so now but like that's really
the only option yeah is to really
approach it from like an [ __ ]
yeah you gotta yeah we got a great davis
and schwarzenegger here you just gotta
you can't on the sidewalk bro like you
can't have a barbecue on the sidewalk i
know the rat is fire but you got to get
the [ __ ] out of here
i've been seeing some man at least 20 to
25 times in the last six months or so
i've either witnessed [ __ ] out
here smoking crack
or [ __ ] just i'll just pull up and
there's just a guy [ __ ] on the
sidewalk yeah and i'm like bro
yeah i do business right here yeah no
[ __ ] over there yeah the amount of
homeless men you've i mean i've seen
it's just like bro like what is that now
it's like that is a thing
it's unoriginal now i'm just like every
nigga's ass that out here everybody
they're all naked bruh it's crazy it's a
lot of mental health i mean it's like
yeah it's like there's a lot of mental
health and it's a lot of like foster
kids who uh got kicked out and it's like
yo
because obviously if you go to a shelter
you gotta be drug free
right so a lot of these people are like
yo what like yo man i'll be seeing some
of these [ __ ] homeless little
encampments that look kind of fire
that's what i'm saying though dawg they
got four glass mattresses and they got
their own little
i was on wilshire and la brea the other
day at a barbecue you know what i mean
the homeless encampment [ __ ] was [ __ ]
lit are you kidding me
that wasn't really but you know what i
mean
bro
come when what yeah no it's like it's
like uh it's like you know it used to be
downtown you knew was like bad but now
it's like everywhere it's like
[ __ ] skid row everywhere dude
everywhere bro melrose like that you
know melrose not even catch area but
like you know going down like the
fairfax district it's crazy over there
you saw that uh that [ __ ] on the tv
right with the hidden little metal ball
jersey
yeah
the dude tried to pull up and rob them
and he [ __ ] pulled out he had one on
him i was like
this wild west [ __ ] hell yeah i am
scared yeah callie's crazy and then the
thing is like that dude if they i don't
know if they ever ended up finding that
guy who shot them dudes but he's going
to be the one that gets in trouble no no
he's victim he's victim that's the thing
he had a gun no way he had that gun
legally i mean
i don't know that kid uh the shoe palace
[ __ ] just last week
isn't that [ __ ] up on tv like what's
what's up on melrose that was a 16 year
old
they arrested him telling him it was a
16 year old kid who killed a shoe power
somebody better get these kids over some
[ __ ] sneakers yeah better get these
kids back in school bro it's crazy
yeah no that's real that's an
interesting point cause you think about
they can't go play football they can't
go play basketball you know what i mean
they're bored they're bored so they're
robbing people that's what that's by the
way that's what usually happens the guy
who killed pop smoke was 15. damn
stripes that's [ __ ] 15 or 16.
and then these airbnbs that every artist
gets in town everybody knows about it
right bro like benny the butcher was
here the other day and he was like yeah
we're going to do a little function at
an airbnb like a private party and i was
like bro do me a favor don't do that
don't do that
this was like a few days ago i'm like
bro you're gonna
like
everybody knows oh look that's the pool
at that one so we know where they're
staying at yeah
everybody got their everybody got their
unemployment and there's only children
20 of these airbnb mansions in the hills
that like rappers would actually like to
rent so it's like it's like they're easy
pickings bro it's like dude like you're
gonna post where you're at and everyone
knows what each of these houses and
everybody's got a gun now right like
everybody used their use their edd get a
gun and they're just like all right i'm
in the game now yeah shit's crazy man uh
what's next for you though man
i got a lot of [ __ ] uh
we'll talk offline about some of the
[ __ ] but i mean just yeah everybody
check out rose battle every tuesday we
do that thing at 10 30 or 10 minutes on
the mint comedy is that yeah man yeah
get the mint app it's through like
verizon media or whatever but yeah just
get it just mint comedy reelman comedy
uh online or dot com and you said you
were saying is jeff ross still involved
tuesday oh yeah every tuesday it's me
and jeff getting after it special guests
like freddie gibbs sam j you know all
that type [ __ ]
yeah i i wonder if fred's gonna do
another uh
coco
oh he's got to i think he is he'll do
another drop
a little comedy drive i was how i didn't
i wasn't i was out of town uh how do you
how was his first comedy night you know
freddy's funny he is he's a natural he's
gonna be all right uh it was great he he
gradually got better that's what it was
it was like he opened you know he'll
normally host a comedy show
and he made it like to host a comedy
show you also kind of have to be funny
word and then he just
that fearless thing is a real thing bro
like when you don't when you don't feel
like you've got nothing to lose you just
are great and he's also he's not afraid
to uh to look stupid or look or to like
fail from a comedy perspective and he's
just that's what makes him so great he's
like yeah you can get me or like i can
follow my facebook i'll be right back up
you know like keep that same energy if
you're talking [ __ ] about me while i'm
down and he keeps that he does that with
everything he does acting comedy yeah
rapping
raising his kids i know you're a big
hip-hop head we have a similar taste in
the in the music [ __ ] who who is like
some of the music that you're
appreciating over the last year and some
changes man obviously griselda right you
know obviously you know big rap uh
but i like roam streets and rick hi hi
now
i mean specialist crazy you're man's
yeah so that's that's who i'm i'm into
you know obviously uh what navy blue and
those cats and they did the thing with
the alchemist so uh
pink sufi them kind of cats sideshow
shout out slideshow uh sci shows like
the only cat i know talking about the uh
the ethiopia uh genocide that's
happening in the tigritt region i didn't
even know that was a thing [ __ ] this is
what i'm talking about you but you knew
about the gaza and free palestine [ __ ]
because all the celebrities writing
letters but there's literally a genocide
happening right now and nobody's talking
about it because because there's no
special because because nip ain't here
like does nipple talk about it well
there's all yeah well i mean to be fair
like one there's not a ethiopian
celebrity besides nip right um
who
is like on the forefront of the culture
exactly i think ruby rose might be
ethiopian yeah scishow talks about it
but not like and also too like i feel
like
you know
low-key like the us only gets involved
in those kind of
things that benefit them like like what
are the numbers so what's what are the
streams what are the streams
what kind of what kind of natural
resources are in ethiopia so we could go
and help out yeah
that is that is america they're just
like all right
yeah put a military base here [ __ ] i
like all this [ __ ]
oh they got poppy fields over there
right right
oh they got oil over there
oh
they got money over there
that's great i didn't know there was a
genocide happening yeah nobody's talking
about it please talk about it please
spread the word there is a yeah there is
a humanitarian issue happening in the
atria i'm sorry not even you know it's
not it get that out of my face it's
ethiopia in the tigre region yeah
they're starving them
was
was
just like tiffany had she's atrian
there's a big history in population in
l.a but uh
but yeah this is this is ethiopia and
the tegra region it's like that's just
been going since november so before the
israel and palestine conflict that
happened again in in gaza and all these
[ __ ] wrote letters but then it's like
okay there's still another one happening
over here bro you know like are we
picking and choosing the the holocaust
we're supporting now
that's wild yeah i didn't know that like
if yeah if like if this genocide was
sponsored by like you know taco bell and
red bull [ __ ] be like okay cool can i
livestream down on hulu what's up
yeah you know it's a lot of this fake
woke [ __ ] man it does it's that popular
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying
so what we talking about again uh i
don't remember what we were talking
about top five genocides top five
genocides of all time
top five i would say what uh the ming
dynasty right or
the uh
ming dynasty what about the uh what's
the genghis khan and then
that's bill russell yeah he might be the
michael jordan he might yeah he might be
on some ghost [ __ ]
shout out yo you know what's crazy is i
only know about how crazy genghis khan
was because i listen to joe road
we'll be talking about this [ __ ] all the
time
genghis khan bro yeah he's got this
guy's name is the rafters uh i don't
even like oh i mean like is hitler even
like top five and he's gotta be he's
gotta be somewhere in there i don't
think he's top three
i don't know if we talk in genocide all
the time since the world is i mean yeah
stalin stalin got numbers
yeah and during hitler
yeah he was there
longevity
longevity but hitler had had the best
press because he killed the jews you
know what i mean so he was smart you
know
i'm just going to stay silent hey i'm
saying oh it's it's a it's a it's a it's
a bad joke
it's a joke and bad taste saying you got
the press because ethiopia because we
got i got
that's crazy so yeah everyone go
research that and yeah shut up yeah is
there a way to donate
i don't know man the way donate i mean
people look online and see what you can
do like go by go fly over there get some
freedom fighters over there and get rid
of that [ __ ] like we got to stop with
all this like yeah this selective
outrage yes well it's really just like
what you said was right it's really just
a matter of like whatever celebrities
get behind the people though yeah and
it's like you guys know you have a
platform like all i'm hearing is
celebrities say give vaccinate they're
not talking about like well hey listen i
understand this and i understand your
choice and i respect your choice like
this shit's crazy to me like it's just
you get vaccinated here you're stupid or
you get vaccinated you're gonna hurt my
family and you're like i just saw um
some celebrity just said the hell with
your freedom was it arnold
schwarzenegger i don't even know i mean
joe joe biden said the the um vaccinated
the scourge of the country i'm like my
nick is right next to me you know what i
mean like bro i know so many people who
are unvaccinated they're not they're not
bad people at all you're just like jeez
is this what trump is talking about
there's good people on both sides
no man
yeah i'm sorry i'm dropping bars i
thought this was the bars show kev bars
ain't that kev you going in bruh [ __ ]
spitting go in bruh spit spit that [ __ ]
yeah um who's your favorite comedian
of all time brian moses if you had to
it's richard pryor richard pryor that's
easy you wanna you wanna you wanna mount
rushmore give me the mount rushmore
richard pryor
love chris rock i love chris rock bigger
and blacker little chris rock love dave
chappelle of course and i think fourth
is
ellen degeneres alan yeah ellen and i
think uh cute little b ellen degeneres
yeah because i think ellen dropped her
first her first hbo special is like
it's one of the greatest of all time
because she's just all about economy of
words you know if you're into punch
lines and you know just that was that
was a master class on like how to how to
do it to me i was like yo like dave
chappelle gives you that truth right
dick gregory he's kind of in that mold
of dick gregor i love dick you know and
paul mooney like he will say what needs
to be said same thing as chris rock
they're kind of in those same molds
right richard pryor is he can do
everything like he's he's in like for
people who have things in their bag he
can do everything he can do improv he
can do you know he can battle you you
know i mean if you need to be rose he'll
battle he can do crowd work you know
he's got stories he's got characters you
know he's got set up punch i mean the
guy is that's the guy i mean like he is
he's jesus or you know he's he's
he's the god of comedy because he can do
everything right uh and in a high level
high clip and then you have those other
two i really like because that's more of
my mold and then just ellen from a
technical standpoint because she's got
bars
i don't think ellen gets enough respect
as a comedian yeah no and then yeah you
know it's a it's a man's sport for the
most part because that's who's here so
why would she
i always look at like either you know
either her or roseanne is like the two
chick goats
yeah before roseanne yeah rosa [ __ ]
roseanne was a yeah she was she was ill
yeah
as a kid i'm like man roseanne was so
[ __ ] funny on tv yeah i liked her too
and then like yeah obviously you know
your patrice is coming up now you're
bill birds that kind of a thing you know
yeah out of that new class right like
who do you think is like has the best
chance of cracking that mountain because
i think that for me it's probably bill
burr
i mean he's burped yeah burger's got to
keep going and patrice would have still
been alive i mean i think patrice
doesn't get enough yeah if patrice was
like he'd be going hard against all this
[ __ ] right now it's like we don't have
that no more nobody's willing to go out
there and be like they just want to be
on the side of right so so they can get
the retweets because social media kind
of [ __ ] everything up it's just like
it's not about talent you know what i
mean it's not about you know
it's now it's about following which kind
of really makes it real but then it's
also like
you're talking about following kind of
almost like 80s hair metal or just
popular music it's like is motley crue
still a thing it's poisonous there was
no substance to that music yeah so like
you know some of the cats who are big
now it's like there are great internet
you know born comedians but you know
there's a lot who aren't and then they
they're getting the rooms right now who
would you say is like has the best
chance to crack uh crack the mount
rushmore of combat not your personality
yeah but overall
i mean you can't deny joe rogan what he
did for the podcasting community and
just like he really he and mark maron
kind of single-handedly like hey there's
another lane right there there's there's
a new money stream here and those cats
are kind of leading that way so i think
just those guys you know uh if seinfeld
stays alive like it's gonna be him as
long as he doesn't bill cosby you know
what i mean uh i mean i should hope not
yeah yeah uh i mean ck if ck can come
back from this you know he'll he'll have
a story to tell kind of a thing um i
think louis ck was is so [ __ ]
ridiculously hilarious yeah
and uh man yeah
and by the way i i can't forget about
david till i mean like that's listen
yeah people don't talk about david tell
enough i mean that is every comics
comics comic con i mean like born or
alive you look at david tell you're like
well yeah i want to be like that you
know what i mean like economy of words
funny i mean just off the cuff some
stuff you like it takes you a minute to
get you just like did he really just say
that that's crazy oh my god you know
he's just
he's he's a sniper you know he's you
know he can spell you see louis c.k
making a comeback from his
quote-unquote cancellation
uh yeah i do
i do because he's got a following and uh
like chris delia crystal is going to
come back too you know he's got a
following so because the internet exists
and because podcasting exists right and
because louie kind of had a he built a a
fan base before he got him done i would
love to see him do a podcast
who literally
yeah but he's more of a written guy he
wants to look so [ __ ] funny man yeah
and like what i always loved about him
was again like he just doesn't give a
[ __ ] like i love comedians who just
don't care yeah he doesn't give a [ __ ]
to a point where he's like can i just
master right in front of you like you
didn't give a [ __ ] just pull out and
jerk off while you're in the room and
clearly he doesn't give a [ __ ] literally
yeah maybe a bit too much he's trying to
give a [ __ ] little
bit more
yeah
he did kind of just jerk off in front of
yeah you know female counterparts yeah
you know
yeah baxter run backs [ __ ]
yeah hey man yeah shout out shout out i
think um i think joe rogan though like
like you said like
the whole podcasting world is just
another stratosphere for comedians now
yeah and what he does for like it's like
joe rogan what he does for you know
everybody like he allows because he is
the king of the influence right now he's
like he's the stern of podcasting it's
he does kind of allow everybody to kind
of say what they want like he can be the
punchline like stern even starting to be
a punchline you know just because
they're kings of the media in that sense
but
now everything's open everybody so we
can go do everything because this guy's
like no no we got to keep freedom of
speech you know i mean like we have to
be able to say these harsh words and say
these harsh things that way we can get
to the good [ __ ] you know but maintain
the freedom that way they start taking
away [ __ ] then they'll just start
picking issues what they want to take
away and that's that you know that
the woke mob or whatever the [ __ ] it is
but it's like that getting rid of speech
thing or you can't joke about that like
when people came at michael che about
simone bilas it was like
okay like he retweeted some [ __ ] that
was that was awful
but i'm glad we're talking about it
right and that's kind of the end of the
day it's like we're talking about hard
[ __ ] but i'm glad we're talking about it
and like if we can start a conversation
that's what colin kaepernick these are
the conversations kaepernick wanted to
have oh my god the fact that like dude
the kaepernick conversation really
pisses me off
just the fact that like just the
hypocrisy on the right of america and on
the ship that they pick and choose to
like get offended by so crazy to me
right everybody i mean both sides of the
gangs you know i mean the uh no no no no
i think the extreme the extreme on each
side is [ __ ] crazy right
no they got exposed everybody's exposed
now everybody's exposed now okay so now
you can pick and choose to see like who
your real ones are like who are you
going to go on a foxhole with
by the way it's like it's like rome
streets he's got this uh this bar where
he says like i keep my circle close like
deuce deuce entry wounds i mean that
[ __ ] stuck with me i was like you got to
keep your circles small bro because
these [ __ ] are actors out here
especially in show business you know you
forget that you know it's like it's
almost like that bad joe song like 98 of
these [ __ ] carry guests none of these
[ __ ]
these rappers are all actors you're like
okay [ __ ] you're right
98 of you comics don't carry guns this
is true um
is it someone who's been on rogan's
podcast a lot he gets a lot of credit
for
twice sure yeah twice um but he gets a
lot of credit for kind of being like a
quote unquote king maker he's brought a
lot of comedians he put a lot of people
on but a lot of people on bro not even
like he's doing it to be like i put
people on he just he's like nick cannon
yeah
yeah but like is is white nick cannon
rogan is the white nick cannon you heard
it here first buzzwords buzzwords
clickbait clickbait
no but but um
as someone who's been on his podcast is
it is the effect of being like is it is
that like a real thing like do you
notice the
the like bump or the jump in like
like all like like how big of a deal is
that i'll say this uh on at the comedy
store we had a show called tiny sets
which was like uh npr's tiny desk we had
a band behind
cats doing a stand-up right in like a
really small area with like you know um
before covet it was or yeah we just had
a little audience for no audience um
but uh there was crazy comments on the
comedy store uh instagram and youtube
talking about black comic street at the
show right they were like ah
like crazy [ __ ] and then that black
comic his name is jamar neighbors you
can check out that tiny set on the
comedy store instagram but when jamar
did rogan literally all that [ __ ]
changed the week after that then they
could stop being racist and we're like
oh we [ __ ] with you
just because he did legitimately because
he did that
what comments changed after like like
clockwork it was crazy it's like you
just need a white savior to be like no
no no everybody
he's one of the good ones and then they
stopped right right i'm like so yeah
that's influence like you can stop
racist from being racist
that's so crazy yeah that's rogan do you
think rogan knows that he has that like
he does
because
that shit's crazy to me isn't it
isn't it like you bro you could you
could stop a lot of [ __ ] just with
influence you know what i mean but he
allows everybody to kind of do their
thing he's talking about freedom of
speech like he can't stop people's
thoughts
you know so that's why he's great it's
like
it's like when people are like they
watch stanford like oh you know all my
friends they sound funny i can do stand
up that's like when i see comics or
they're like actors being like
he's just talking to people you know
he's just interviewing people i could
interview people people tell me i could
be a podcast it's like no there's a
skill to it man and people don't get
that part about him you know like you
can hate him all day but that nigga's a
hell of an interviewer to his fan base
and it seems to be a lot of people yeah
and he can listen to both sides there
may be some misinformation happening out
there between them but that's a [ __ ]
but that's the conversation but that's
naturally going to happen when you're
sitting there talking to someone for
three hours thank you yeah that's what i
appreciate about his shows he's like i
don't watch every episode but i probably
like i probably watch about half of like
what he puts out and like i appreciate
the fact that like i might not agree
with joe on some [ __ ] but at the same
time like i know i can go and watch
i know i can go watch the conversation
he has with someone who i can't stand
like ben shapiro there you go and i'll
be like hey man he held him under the f
over the fire more than anyone else
would right and have like a constructive
conversation he's not trying to argue
yeah he's trying he's not trying to talk
to down to anybody
yeah yeah so it's like for like joe
rogan like i feel like his kiss show is
a nice middle ground
whereas to most most people who do
interviews or or talk to people
especially on the political side they
all have an agenda
it's like they have an agenda or a cause
they're fighting for yeah so everything
they do is very biased or like you said
if they have someone on the show that
they're that they don't agree with
it's very clear yeah now joe's like his
i think his perspective is like let's
see how your mind works that's why i
always [ __ ] with with bill maher to an
extent because i was bill maher would
always bring right-wing people on the
show and like if bill maher
outside of being you know saying some
dumb [ __ ] bill maher said some dumb [ __ ]
yeah
but like
if the left is like
doing some out of hand like ridiculous
[ __ ] then we'll call him out and i feel
like that's one more more people man
we're too tribal bro like i'm so tired
of this tribal [ __ ]
where it's like bro like you don't have
to agree with everything yeah that woke
america want you to agree with yeah no
america loves here this is what's good
about america like you can start cults
here you can start that [ __ ] magga you
know what i mean like you could just
start it and then like use it as a tax
write-off so like that's why this shit's
like people love this [ __ ] scientology
gangs and [ __ ] people love this [ __ ]
mormons bro we love this [ __ ] out here
yeah christianity judaism oh yeah i'm an
atheist so i'm i'm i'm i'm you're in a
gang you're still in game i'm not in any
gang i'm just like hey
i don't know all this [ __ ] is you're in
the control group bro yeah i guess yeah
i guess i'm just not in the republic i'm
not in the petri dish i'm outside of it
i'm in the control group i get you yeah
you're an atheist yeah you think you're
out of it yeah the cult [ __ ] as well
yeah we are in a world of of of little
cults everyone's in a cult everybody
loves everybody loves to be accepted by
somebody because social media you know
crushed all of our our self-esteem so
now we got to be accepted by certain
groups and we in these groups and if
these [ __ ] don't ride with us gang
gang it's some gang [ __ ] man yeah we
want some gang [ __ ] yeah she's cool
people got but but what's crazy is most
people are are somewhere
we only hear from the people who have
uh trump flags hanging off their f-150s
yeah or from like really outraged
twitter people we don't hear from like
just normal people that we actually know
in real life and that's most of the
people yeah most of the people aren't
they're in the middle they're they're
just like yo man like what are we doing
yeah exactly
at this point i don't even know it's
like it really is it's like oh black
lives matter oh you don't like black
guys matter oh you're real you don't
like black people or it's like all right
well uh backs and you know antibiotics
[Music]
you're not vaccinated you voted for
trump yeah it's just like yeah but uh
martial
yeah oh [ __ ]
jesus
who's not a murderer these days i mean
if you don't got a body in america i
mean like are you really american
yeah i mean who who did you want uh to
kill don't do that no no no i mean if i
could kill anybody who would it be
anyway no we're not gonna go down that
uh no i was gonna say when you when when
you know obviously uh
i'm assuming you weren't a trump guy no
trump was the worst right so when the
when the democrats laid out their their
their pool of 38 [ __ ] who was
the person that you liked for the dems
that year
because it's true the [ __ ] hat couldn't
have been joe biden no it wasn't gonna
be joe um
who did i like i mean
i like kanye
you know what i mean there's been
there's been church it would have been
like
transitioning from like season four of
trump to like
a whole another like spin-off show yeah
i mean because like listen man
everybody's basically unstable at this
point so it's just like let's just go
hard
i was a bit i liked the bernie and uh i
liked uh chelsea gabbard
bernie's cool i get the bernie of it all
i like the bernie of it all maybe stacey
abrams would have been cool
yeah i don't i don't really know i mean
i just want killer mike to run for
president one day there's that you know
there's definitely that they're talking
about the rock too you know he's i would
vote for the rock he's he's kind of a
stranger to the moderator i feel like
i'd vote for the rock without knowing
anything like he don't like he
i'm
writing it in we're going for do i mean
the rock if the rock ran for president
i'm voting for him and he's gonna get
them redneck wrestling [ __ ] to
vote for him too just off gp yeah
yeah i don't know man i i don't know i
mean like i talk to a lot of black
people right now and they're like man
trump had my wallet right though
yeah you know what i mean you know
what's crazy is like
and you know who's who's more capitalist
and american than the american black
person so i got to a point where
i was like not talking to family members
over donald trump word right because i
would see the [ __ ] they'd post on
facebook and i would just be like all
right i can't i can't
reason with this this [ __ ] yeah
to me it's hard to reason with the
people who have the facebook posts and
the [ __ ] trump flags and like those
people are crazy people just so you just
confession kev just so you know i did
buy a trump golf shirt out of trump
towers that my parents were staying at
it was because how long ago was this
this was like his first year i mean i
thought it was funny you know i mean it
was very expensive it was like 70 bucks
but that [ __ ] never wrinkles it's a
great polo fair enough yeah yeah and my
folks folks hate going because you know
they didn't vote for him but like they
uh they didn't um
they were like uh we're staying at these
trump towers but it's like it was
another
no is it trump towers in vegas right
right yeah and they were like they were
pissed because they had a timeshare but
like they renovated the building to a
trump tower and they were just like well
this is where we are now sorry man i'm
like i don't give a [ __ ] but i want
these shirts these are not but like
i i still
feel the way i feel about trump like i
can't stand him i despise him as a
person i thought like the energy he
brought to the to the world was
dangerous yeah
but then i have conversations with
people who i didn't even know were trump
supporters who i know to be like
reasonable and i don't want to use the
word trump supporters people who voted
for him because i don't think i think
there's like kind of like a difference
right yeah
and it was really like
i st you know i could see like you said
on the on the money [ __ ]
if someone says to me man [ __ ]
i was running it up during trump's
presidency so i [ __ ] with trump i'm
talking like black people mexican people
who i know voted for him oh it was also
like 80s crack [ __ ] it was just like
[ __ ] he was making money
we went through a [ __ ] pandemic and
the stock market took a [ __ ] but it
popped right the [ __ ] back up
and the housing market what's going on
in the housing market right now is
insane how are we in the middle of a
[ __ ] pandemic yeah that crypto is
just different
that's like yeah during pandemics like
you could like you could get a crazy bag
of some dogecoin oh my i did yeah i know
a few folk i know a few folks who got
yeah did you did you [ __ ] with the uh i
didn't get in the crypto i didn't get
into the crypto
not yet and i saw i saw dope you know i
can get the crypto i [ __ ] with the
crypto crypto's booming man yeah
you ain't trying to tell nobody can i
see you over there no no no i've been
[ __ ] with the crypto i mean you know
i made some money on bitcoin and then uh
i did the doge thing and then it took a
[ __ ] after that saturday night live
sunday who are you who are your top
three presidents who you got that dude i
don't even know kev i mean i like barack
okay so barack is your first one if i i
mean
i was only alive for clinton barack gw
trump and
wait no the first bush i was born in 87
so the first bush
i i guess since i've been alive yeah
can i go barack turn one brock turn two
and then i guess bill clinton yeah even
though bill clinton's like a [ __ ]
demon yeah
bro i got a crazy story all right so
here's another name drop so because
roswell's so popular and jeff you know
and uh john mayer are friends this is
back when john was dating katy perry
right and uh you know he she had a party
at her house and uh we went jeff brought
me or whatever and uh we were hanging
out met the family the other pairs
whatever and um at her place she had
these like framed
um presidential letters right from like
all the pre all the past alive
presidents like jimmy carter uh the
bushes
i think uh the reagan's because i think
reagan was still alive at the point when
reagan died i don't even know but i
think it was from the live ones but i
definitely was jimmy carter was there it
was the bushes you know george and uh
and w and uh the clintons not the
clintons i'm sorry the obamas
and they all said this jimmy carter is
like oh me and my wife you know we're
thinking about you right uh the bush is
like oh yeah me and you know barbara
thinking about you george w i mean
right yeah so does someone write these
yeah no yeah the obama same thing like
me and michelle thinking about you you
know on your 30th kind of a thing and
then you get to bill clinton's letter
right before the obamas because it's all
in order bill clinton is like just me
sitting here thinking about you you know
it's just him like no mention of hillary
i read that whole [ __ ] i was
like really everybody else is like me
and my wife clinton was just like you
know just there's no way bill clinton
wasn't [ __ ] [ __ ] on epstein island
man he had to have been sleeping with
under i mean speculation i uh you know
shout out to bill because i know they
can be getting [ __ ] killed
chill bill bro so i'm trying to chill
bill i did say you were my third
favorite chill bill
you're going both obama presidencies and
then clinton now if you could have a
beer with any president yeah
i would still go with barack probably
yeah maybe barack but i'm gonna say gw
second well gw parties i feel like we
could
bring some cocaine fruit for george yeah
because i know he's he's had a stent
with the yayo right right right right
and i feel like i feel like george w
bush would be the funniest youtuber if
youtube was around like when he was a
kid like he might be steve will do it
man a beer with the president who
wouldn't enslave me let me think uh i
guess barack probably i mean i'm taking
the barack beer all day yeah brock beer
all day yeah i think that's got to be
everybody's and then probably yeah
clinton and george w i think those are a
great three to have beers with honestly
and you know i don't know if i'm having
a beer with clinton because i feel like
he might have [ __ ] children
so
i'm probably going to go dw second okay
then all right then i'll replace yeah my
top three with uh because listen man i
i'm an fdr and and teddy roosevelt i'm a
roosevelt's you know all day i just
think those those cats kind of killed it
um
but or abe you know afraid the slaves i
mean john f kennedy be fired to be like
yo so what's up with the what marilyn
monroe the kennedys is marilyn monroe
are you kidding actually it's got to be
them they've got the money and they get
john f kennedy was [ __ ] bro
he was out here doing his thug dizzle
right
can you imagine if john f kennedy was
the president in 2021 how much f kennedy
how much screen shots would be dropped
about him sliding in bitch's dms dawg
he'd be [ __ ] i bet you if john f
kennedy was a president in the last 10
years he'd have [ __ ] rihanna
damn
whoa
whoa hot take bro there's no way john
jfk is taking down rihanna bro jfk
rihanna i mean that's crazy that's crazy
a great press i'd go with that wouldn't
that work rihanna's the first lady
nah he would be she'd be the side [ __ ]
wow first eyepiece
wow that's a hell of a title by the way
first side first yeah first side chick
yeah
and marilyn monroe would have only fans
for sure oh my god we should have an
only fans then it'll be fire super fire
fire in the booth fire are you described
only fans at all
no but everybody i know is because you
know that's that's the hustle and shout
out yeah shout out the sex work it's a
hell of a hustle for everybody i saw in
new york it's like those coins well they
just decriminalized um
prostitution in new york i think in new
york they did yeah they look up wait
really so
it's massages it's not illegal but it's
decriminalized that's like just a
misdemeanor now yeah i suppose damn for
selling massages and and some of that
position you could rub and tug and
not not worry about what happened to the
owner of the patriots
right so yeah gotta stick to new york
congratulations yeah like way to respect
sex work you know as like as a
profession california's next gotta be we
better be all these only fans out here
player
yeah
anyway well look uh go check out
every tuesday on the mint comedy for
people who aren't in la you can go to
the comedy store on tuesdays get your
tickets yeah uh you got some other stuff
you're working on you're gonna tell me
about off the camera yeah yeah
we've been trying to convince freddy
gibbs into a podcast for the last like
six months and dog he's too busy working
on classic albums yeah he's a monster um
uh yeah so roast battle tuesdays the
mint comedy app
go support that and uh
man are you are do you do a podcast no
i'm waiting on uh i'm waiting on fred
we're waiting on i got i mean we have
the hospital podcast that's coming back
um
yeah i got some things working out but
yeah just hit that men comedy act
subscribe to roast battle you know what
i mean uh check us out on instagram
twitter all that nonsense and you know
check me out real brian moses and at
race banning boom
by the way your twitter's hilarious
guy's twitter's flagrant as [ __ ] yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] it's [ __ ] great
yeah you be tweeting some crazy [ __ ]
yeah bro i got jobs too like bro i
forgot you tweeted you tweeted like some
movie poster that was racist as [ __ ] and
you're like hollywood when we were
remaking this one oh yeah yeah yeah i
think it was a boss [ __ ] yeah yeah
with uh fred williamson yeah
remake remake yeah go follow him on
twitter too man appreciate you coming
through brother love you though